i get asked this question all the time  should i employ an architect the simple  answer is yes it doesn't matter what  your project is if it's a simple  alteration addition or the largest  commercial building you can think of at  the end of the day architects are  skilled professionals to help you  achieve whatever it is you're trying to  in the building and construction  industry now i know there's going to be  some backlash to this and i know that  some people are going to say you  definitely do not need an architect but  at the end of the day these are people  like myself who have trained for decades  to be able to get to a position in their  career where they can offer you advice  to be able to instill the best practice  moving forward to be able to either save  you money or give you exactly what  you're after at the end of the day